З чотирма ампутаціями - на обох ногах і руках - він катається на роликах,
велосипеді, танцює, стрибає на батуті та у басейн - і усе це фільмує
для підписників у TikTok, приймаючи дедалі нові челенджі.
Його відео набирають сотні тисяч і навіть мільйони переглядів.
Однак такої популярності Данило Мельник собі не бажав.
Ще півтора року тому навіть уявити не міг, що стане ветераном у 19 років,
пройшовши російський полон.
Одразу дуже сильно били. "Будемо каструвати вас, очі вирізати…" Кажу: "Окей, ок".
Тримати моральний дух всіх, хто разом. Тому що це якості нормального сержанта.
Такі якості, які в мене були, розвинулися ще до полону.
Усе, що до повномасштабного вторгнення знав про армію та воєнні дії,
Данило вивчав на заняттях у Львівській військовій академії.
Туди вступив, бо з дитинства мріяв стати розвідником.
Однак дочекатися випускного у Львові навесні 2022-го йому не судилося.
У цей час він уже воював на Київщині.
Потрапив у засідку в Бучанському районі. Це була ніч, і, на жаль, засідка була дуже щільна.
Ми понесли досить великі втрати. Перші прильоти з танка по моїй машині полетіли,
контузія досить така сильна, мені розбило каску, осколками посікло ноги.
Я вже заліг, пересувався далі, ще трошки повів вогонь, і знову постріл був з танка,
це ще одна контузія, і осколками мені зачепило ліву кисть, праву руку трохи зачепило.
І я вже розумію, що втрачаю кров досить швидко…
Від поранення Данило почав втрачати свідомість у одному із сільських дворів, неподалік місця бою.
Галюцинації були досить цікаві, як я в госпіталі прокидаюся, в палаті, вже повна впевненість,
що вже була евакуація, що я в госпіталі, і мої хлопці всі стоять, мають купу "волонтерки".
Я кричу їм: пацани, дайте води, пацани, дайте води!
Прокидаюся - а я все одно там, і ніякого госпіталя немає. І знайшли мене москалі.
Вони ходили по дворам, ламали замки, щось шукали для себе, і знайшли мене.
То я одразу їх попросив застрелити мене, тому що я не хотів з ними говорити.
Але далі чекала не смерть, а ще гірше, розповідає Данило:
два тижні полону спершу в Білорусі, а потім два місяці у Курському СІЗО,
по суті, без жодної медичної допомоги.
Я вже в дуже плачевному стані, в мене гниють всі осколкові мої поранення,
і день-два - я вже "від'їду". Всі хлопці попадали вже в критичному стані.
Нікого, якщо взяли в полон з пораненням, одразу нікого в лікарню не везли.
Або в СІЗО, або десь якийсь підвал, або щось, щоб всі доходили до критичного стану, до ампутації.
Не знаю чого так, це, мабуть, спеціально…
І там я пробув, мені там ампутували фаланги пальців на ногах.
Після допитів росіяни передали Данила разом з іншими важкопораненими на обмін полоненими.
Коли в квітні 2022-го він повернувся в Україну, лікарі констатували:
ампутувати доведеться обидві стопи і одну кисть.
Я зайняв позицію такого більш позитиву. Тому що я живий, реально,
і мені життя дісталося великою ціною, і я радів цьому.
У госпіталі після обміну зайняв позицію, що мені все одно, на думку інших людей,
що вони там будуть думати. Одразу фоточки собі виставив, який я вже є, після поранення.
Це досить важке рішення було.
Ніжки! Нові ніжки! Уууу!
Це одне з дебютних відео, яке Данило записав для своєї сторінки в TikTok.
Тут він радіє своїм першим протезам. Згодом опублікував кадри з реабілітації:
перші кроки після того, як встав з візка, і як вчився управляти біонічною рукою.
Згодом почав експериментувати зі спортом і показувати своє повсякдення:
як відпочиває з друзями і домашніми улюбленцями, і навіть набиває тату на животі.
Намагаюся показувати в TikTok, в Instagram. Люди дивляться, людям це так само цікаво,
тому що для них це нове, яке для мене стало повсякденним.
І я хотів би, щоб для всіх це стало повсякденністю, тому що цього, на жаль, в нашій країні буде дуже багато.
Це відео для Інстаграму Данило записував у присутності DW.
Нині його челендж - пробігти на максимальній швидкості на біговій доріжці.
Асистує Данилові на зйомках один з його реабілітологів.
Він і співрежисер, і фанат блогу молодого ветерана.
Данила знає вся Америка, де він в основному протезувався, і вся Україна,
оскільки він дуже відомий у нас! Данилові навіть важко було пересісти з крісла колісного
на кушетку, а зараз, я вам скажу, він виконує такі вправи деякі,
що їх важко декому без ампутації виконувати.
Та лише спортом і популярністю в соцмережах Данило Мельник обмежуватися не збирається.
Він активно бере участь у конференціях з реабілітації та інформаційних кампаніях
на підтримку ветеранів з тяжкими пораненнями. Аби привернути увагу до їхніх проблем,
часом навіть знімається у фотосесіях "ню".
А ще - постійно ставить перед собою нові цілі:
навчився без ніг водити автівку і планує здобути освіту психолога.
Хочу вступити на факультет психології та надалі допомагати вже своїм побратимам.
Я дуже не хочу розлучатися з військами. Взагалі це для мене буде велика трагедія.
І в цьому напрямку я зможу служити далі і допомагати Батьківщині.
Попереду в Данила ще тривала реабілітація і нові протези, які він опановуватиме у США.
Хлопець пообіцяв DW та всім своїм підписникам у соцмережах:
йому ще є чим дивувати і надихати.